I called to tell you at length
from the tutor homily on obedience,
first published in 1547 with
its stress on hierarchy,
degree order,
subordination and obedience.
And yet as you know,
within two years of the publication of
that homily in 1547 there was a wave of
peasant protest in 1549 right across the
south of England and open rebellion in
east Anglia cats rebellion.
This was a society in which the common
people below the level of the middling
sought,
the leaders of village society
had no formal political voice.
They were as the Thomas Smith put it to
be ruled over and not to rule others.
And yet not infrequently,
we find those same common people raising
their voices in protest and sometimes
in demand.
It was a society in which
the gentry rulers regarded
their social inferiors with
a great deal of condescension.
The language they use to describe to them
says it all the meaner sot of people,
the clowns,
the rudest sought the rabble and
they expected their deference.
Men were expected to uncover their heads
before their social superiors do them
hat on her as it was called,
women were expected to Bob a curtsy,
and yet this condescension on the part
of the gentry was tingy with anxiety and
an expectation of insubordination.
As one of them said,
John Ugland or put it the common people
are always apt to rebel and mutiny upon
the least occasion.
Well,
how can one reconcile
all of these paradoxes?
Well,
maybe the answer is in fact simple enough.
Deference and obedience was the norm.
It was instilled by precept.
It was learned by
repeated daily experience,
and yet periodically it could perhaps
be destabilized by circumstances,
a famine,
perhaps a particularly callous
example of exploitation by landlord.
Things like that could perhaps
render people desperate,
leading them to rise in a convulsive
spasm of anger and despair.
And when that happened,
all good order could be
threatened by the mob.
What the gentry called
the many headed monster,
the common people,
the beast with many heads,
which a powerful image and not without
historical foundation and yet to
characterize all or even most forms
of popular disturbance in early modern
England in this way is
profoundly misleading.
A generation of research
on popular protesters,
so showing just how inadequate that
stereotype is and the resulting shift of
perception amongst the storylines is
reflected in the kind of language they now
use to describe these things.
People nowadays talk little about the mob.
They talk more about the crowd,
they talk less about revolt and
more about protest and resistance.
We've moved from the study of riots to
the study of what people term popular
political culture.
Okay.
Now whether that term is fully justified,
we'll see,
but the evidence at least reveals
that the common people were neither
unconditionally deferential
to their rulers.
No.
Or on the other hand where they secretly
alienated from the existing social
order,
but rather as one laboring man from North
Hampton share and the English Midlands
put it on one of these occasions,
they could to quote him,
they could tattle well enough.
How to devise a means to help themselves
and they could do that within the
parameters of the prevailing structures
of power and authority within which they
were obliged to work because as yet
no one had suggested any possible
alternative.
Popular protest has been well described
by John Walter as being in the first
instance of politics of subsistence,
a politics of subsistence.
It's most immediate objectives were
frequently the defense or the amelioration
of a threatening economic situation.
The most obvious case of that
was in the case of food riots.
These tended to occur in years of dearth,
bad harvest years when grain was in short
supply and the prices of food rocketed
years like 1587 50 94 to seven 1622
to three 1631 1647 to eight and so on.
Okay.
These riots also occurred in years
of industrial depression when rural
industrial workers in particular who were
dependent upon the market for most of
their food supplies,
found that they lacked the income to
supply themselves because their employers,
we're no longer able to
put out work to them.
1620 saw some very bad industrial
depressions of that kind.
Well either circumstance,
a bad harvest or a year of industrial
slump could produce a sudden and
catastrophic decline in what
economists refer to as People's xchange
entitlements.
As consumers or in plain English,
they were unable to afford
the food that they needed,
agrarian disturbances,
what rather than less predictable,
but they occurred sporadically and
occasionally in areas or individual
communities where the memorial tenants
or the local population more generally
we're confronted with changes which
threatened to undermine the viability of
particular patterns of
local rural economy.
So in 1536 as you know,
part of the causes of the pilgrimage of
grace rising where protests against the
pushing up of entry fines for land
in parts of Northwestern England.
In 1549 cats rebellion was rooted in
protests against the exploitation of
landlords grazing rights.
But above all in the late
16th and dirty 17th centuries,
the grievance which motivated protests
was and closure and closure of the land
which extinguished
rights of common pasture,
pasture rights,
which were particularly valued.
So,
for example,
in the small town of Berkhamsted,
which is just to the northwest of London
in the county of Hartfordshire in 1,618
several villages existed around a very
large area of common land on which they
all had rights to graze
their cattle in sheep.
They had rights to put their
pigs into the woodland.
They had rights to gather for fuel and
wild fruits and to capture small animals
for the pot rabbits in particular.
The loss of all of that when attempts
were made to enclose berkhamsted common
would deeply resented and that's the kind
of situation that's so often occurred.
Now,
situations of that kind
occurred sporadically though.
Sometimes they also came in clusters in
1607 there was a wave of enclosures in
villages where the three counties of
North Hampton share work share and
Leicestershire met in
the Midlands up here.
That was known as the Midland rising
because there was a kind of scattering of
riots across the whole area or again,
in 1628 to 1632 they're occurred what's
known as the western rising in the
forested areas of the west of England.
Those areas were being Disa,
forested and cleared,
and the land turned into when closed farms
and much resistance sprang up amongst
those who had formally enjoyed
common rights in the woodlands.
And finally in the 60 from the 1630s
in response to the drainage of the Fed
lands of eastern England and
the allocation of reclaimed
reclaimed land in and
closed farms to those who
invested in that improvement,
there was a wave of resistance,
the people of the fence to the south of
the wash and in Lincolnshire lost as a
result of the drainage
that grazing rights,
their fishing rights,
they're wild filing rights,
the rights together rushers
and turf for Thatch or fuel.
And they bitterly resisted these
changes in the so called Finland riots,
which actually sputtered
on for over 30 years.
Okay.
So we're dealing primarily with forms of
protest against all forms of resistance
to circumstances which had a detrimental
effect upon the household economies of
the inhabitants of particular districts.
And those circumstances were felt at
one time or another all over England and
Wales.
But there was also rather
than more to it than that,
although it took historians quite a
while to appreciate the fact when people
first started looking closely at the
wreck chords which survive relating to
these events,
the most immediately striking thing
about the evidence was that these risings
revotes or riots were in fact relatively
restrained and relatively purposefully
directed.
Perhaps we'd been misled
by the very term riot,
which was often used to describe
them in the legal records.
That word,
of course conjures up an image
of Urud breakdown of order,
but in fact,
in English law,
a riot was simply an unlawful act
committed by three or more people who had
assembled for the purpose.
As a result,
the reality of those events which are
described conventionally as riots,
could be much less harrowing than the
image which the term tends to conjure up
in our minds.
So take foot egg,
food rights,
for example.
First of all,
they were by no means an automatic
response to the existence of a dearth or
scarcity of food.
They were in fact,
relatively few,
even in pretty bad years.
The form was also relatively restrained.
Crowds didn't simply sees food from anyone
who had a stock of food to be seized.
The gentry or big farmers
with wells stock bonds,
for example.
In fact,
food riots were almost exclusively
directed at middlemen in the grain trade.
They were almost entirely
directed against corn dealers.
Again,
crowds involved in these riots,
rarely stole food and took it away.
More likely,
they involve the stopping of
middlemen who were transporting grain,
which they had bought up in bulk in
market and forcing them to sell it to the
crowd at prices below
the inflated market rate.
That's to say at prices which local
people thought they could afford.
And finally,
they very rarely involved violence
against people quite often,
food riots involved or even led by women
who could be quite violent in their
language and their threats,
but rarely physically violent.
The object was to prevent the removal
of grain to keep it in the area and to
force those who had it,
to sell it to local people rather
than to attack them personally.
So essentially it appears to be the
case that these were protests against
dysfunctions in the developing
internal traffic in foodstuffs.
Such a trade,
especially in grain,
was essential to supply England's
growing cities and those areas of the
countryside,
which are often described as dependent
areas which didn't produce enough grain
for the local populations needs.
But the system of internal trade which
was developing was not yet sufficiently
well developed to iron out regional
inequalities in the supply of food stuffs
which was available in bad years.
And in addition,
that system offered opportunities
or temptations to evade the law.
The law stated that the poor should
always be served first in the market at
prices which were agreed by the
market officer's as reasonable.
Before large scale commercial
dealers were allowed to participate.
Yet that law was frequently
flouted in Hartfordshire,
for example,
to the north of London in 1598 the local
justice has had to deal with a major
problem of large scale dealers who
were supplying the London food market
intercepting grain before it
ever came to the local markets,
buying it on the road and
removing it immediately to London.
Problems.
Of that kind could provoke a
great deal of local resentment.
And this kind of situation helps to
explain the geography of food riots.
They tended to take place in or near
market towns in heavily populated areas
with many consumers,
dependent funders,
markets they took place in or around
market towns of food exporting areas where
the local poor witnessed commercial
dealers buying up supplies at prices which
they couldn't afford in order
to ship the grain elsewhere.
And they occurred in areas that such
dealers passed through on their way to
major urban markets in particular,
one finds a lot of food,
uh,
food rioting in the market
catchment area of London,
in the southeast and in the South
West around the great city of Bristol.
Similarly to a lesser degree
around knowledge in East Anglia.
So these actions were aimed at
rectifying quite specific forms of local
grievance,
a sense amongst local populations that
they were being exploited by middlemen in
the grain trade and abused where
there was no such grievance.
The poor seems simply to have tightened
their belts in bad years or even in some
parts of the north and far west.
To have starved quietly,
and those of them who did take action
usually did it in a fairly purposeful
manner,
focusing on achieving a specific end,
supplying their own needs at
prices that they could afford,
defending one could say
in the jargon there,
exchange entitlements.
Well,
similarly,
agrarian disturbances present the less
lurid picture than the one conjured up by
the word riot.
They certainly often involved large crowds
of people who had assembled together
to prevent an enclosure or to reverse
it or to prevent the drainage of Finland
or to reverse it and so forth.
Knocking down hedges and fences,
blocking drainage works and so forth,
but they were also relatively orderly.
Surprisingly often agrarian
riots were announced in advance.
They were even sometimes preceded by
meetings in the local manner court or in
the church at which the tenants
would agree upon their action.
In one village,
for example,
called Righton,
r y,
t,
O,
n up in the northeast of England in 1,607
the manor court actually required all
tenants to turn up with a spade or an
ax in order to take down an enclosure to
which they objected.
They even laid it down in
the manner court as a bylaw,
that any tenant who failed to turn
up to take part would be fine.
Six pens.
Sometimes these actions were initiated
having been agreed upon by a public
signal.
Quite often the tolling
of the church bells,
they frequently involve the
gathering of whole communities,
men,
women,
and children together.
Sometimes they were led by local notables.
Sometimes the minister of the
parish might be the leader.
Sometimes they were led by parish or
memorial officers or members of the
memorial jury.
Uh,
sometimes they even enjoyed the tacit
support of sympathetic local gentleman who
might themselves be losing out
from a particular end closure.
And we're content to encourage some action
against it even though they took part
themselves.
Uh,
one of the reasons that Oliver Cromwell
was so popular in eastern England in the
Fed lands that he came from
was the fact that in 1628,
he had defended the rioters in the fens,
in parliament,
uh,
against the,
innovations that they
were protesting against.
He was known as the Lord of the
fence for his popularity in the area.
It didn't hurt when he later
recruited his regiments.
There.
Riots often involved a
strong element of ritual.
Frequently they involve the ritual
removal of a fence or a hedge.
Sometimes those who pulled down fences
or hedges did it two at a time to avoid
the legal definition of a riot as an
illegal act committed by three or more
persons.
Sometimes the youth or the women of
the community were to the fore in this
action in order to
evade severe punishment.
It was thought that they
would be held less culpable.
Sometimes hedges were pulled
down by men dressed as women.
And this transvestite element
in the ritual of writing is,
it's quite fascinating.
It perhaps symbolize a
world turned upside down.
Now,
no one could have deceived themselves
that these were actually women.
Um,
they had beards for a start,
but,
um,
they,
dressed as women,
sometimes perhaps symbolizing
a world turned upside down.
Fences and hedges once they were destroyed
was sometimes saw an up and burned or
even ritually buried.
Sometimes the land returned into tillage
was ritually plowed to symbolize it's
return to the memorial
community or sometimes where
it was common pasture which
was being defended.
Animals were put back onto it by the
villages in order to symbolize their
reclamation of the common pasture,
and quite often all of this
might be accompanied by a
rather festive atmosphere.
Cakes and Ale were frequently
prepared to be enjoyed afterwards,
often around a bonfire.
Music sometimes accompanied the
proceeding they might be dancing in the
fenlands.
They enjoyed a game which was
known as fenland football.
This was the original form of football
in which large crowds of young men simply
chased across the countryside,
kicking an inflated pig's
bladder in the fenland.
When they got together
for fenland football,
they kicked it across the countryside
and destroyed every drainage ditch that
they passed in the course
of chasing the ball.
It's interesting also that these actions
often took place upon festival days.
The rising in the Midlands in 1,607
started on May Day Shrove Tuesday in
February.
It was often a popular date.
It was a time known for village games,
which involved rituals of inversion
turning the world upside down for a day.
Another popular occasion
was relegation day,
the day on which people perambulator
the boundaries of the parish to note the
parish boundaries.
And that's something I would I return to.
And again,
agrarian risings of this kind very
rarely involved violence against people.
The crowds might appear very threatening.
There were rarely any
injuries to individuals.
Indeed,
those against whom the crowd were rioting
or protesting very often kept out of
the way.
Okay.
So what we're dealing with,
uh,
occasions which were often very highly
targeted and very purposeful affairs
rather than outbreaks of anarchy
and unrestrained violence,
it's equally evident that they were
expressive of a kind of moral order,
which involved not just defense of the
material interests of the community,
important as that was,
but expressed also a set of values.
What eep Thompson in a famous phrase
described as the moral economy of the
crowd,
by which he meant a popular consensus
about the nature of legitimate and
illegitimate practices.
It economic life involving notions
of the proper behavior expected from
different sections of the community and
asserting notions of certain popular
rights in the economic sphere.
Rioters do indeed very often seem to
have been infused with a strong sense of
the rectitude of the act.
They were sustained in that
by certain legitimizing ideas
as one might expect in
agrarian disturbances.
The vital legitimizing
idea was that of custom.
As you know,
in any individual manner,
custom constituted a kind of local lived
in an environment of norms and usages,
a collection of rights
which people believe to have
existed time out of mind to
which the memory of no man is
to the contrary in the phrase,
they often used time out of mind
and to that extent custom provided a
powerful legitimating rhetoric for actions
of this kind.
For example,
in 1630 when the tenants of one manner
in the southwest of England defended
their claim to pasture
rights in the forests,
they were able to produce 10 witnesses
whose average age was 78 quite
extraordinarily old people for this
period who testified to the existence of
their customs in the woodlands during
their own long lives and in those of their
fathers and their grandfathers as they
had been told when they were children.
But in the changing circumstances of
the 16th and early 17th centuries,
custom had become not only a set of
long established rights and practices,
but also in a time of change,
a potential arena of conflict
between landlords and tenants
if the tenants were trying to defend
what they took to be the antiquity and
reasonableness of customs which
protected their interests.
Many landlords were anxious to explode
those claims or to persuade people or to
pressurize people into removing customs,
which inhibited what they saw
as improvement of their estates.
With that kind of conflict of interests.
When push came to shove,
the notion of the sanctity and wisdom
of custom strengthened the arm of those
who tried to resist claims
against local customs,
which were detrimental to their interests.
In the case of enclosure,
they saw themselves also as resisting
a kind of innovation which had been
declared illegal by various statutes
throughout the 16th century.
The laws against enclosure,
in fact,
we were appealed in 1624 but the fact
that enclosure had for long been declared
illegal by parliament was remembered and
that again gave a sense of legitimacy
and some rioters could even
claim a higher authority.
As I mentioned.
Um,
very often end closure riots
took place on relegation day.
That was the day when traditionally the
older members of the village community
gathered together with some of the
youngest members in particular young boys,
to walk the boundaries of the parish,
to beat the bounds as it was called.
The Church of England even had a special
homily for relegation day and it had
some significant texts.
One of them was Deuteronomy 27 17
cursed be he that removes his neighbors
landmark and other was
proverbs 2128 removed,
not the ancient landmark which thy fathers
have set the rituals of walking the
boundaries of the parish.
We're all about such landmarks.
They were all about such boundaries,
such common territories and their sanctity
and they tried to impress upon the
young boys who were part of the
procession where exactly the boundaries,
where there were various
rituals involved in this.
It's a boundary involved,
a stream and one of the boys might be
thrown in the street to help him remember
where it was.
It was common if there were boundaries,
stones to get one of the boys to touch
the stone with his finger after which the
finger was twisted by one of the
elder men to give him a sharp pain,
to remind him one village practice sitting
little boys on the stones with their
bare bottoms.
They sometimes even struck a child at
particular boundary spots so that they
would remember the place.
It was all part of the ritual.
If such occasions sometimes ended with
purposeful attacks upon new fangled
boundaries,
which had been erected in the form of
enclosure and which include excluded local
inhabitants from formerly common land,
then they may very well have had a sense
of divine approval for what they did in
defending their boundaries.
Yeah.
Ask for food.
Rioters,
they had a strong enough sense of their
own rights to have food available at
reasonable prices.
When she was asked what had motivated
her to take part in the stopping of a
grain shipment in 1629 one woman
from Essex said it was the quota,
the cry of the country and my own want
green rioters could also claim with some
justification to be merely enforcing
the law.
They could see themselves as engaging
in a kind of mass citizen's arrest of
grain dealers who were
breaching market regulations.
Or they could see themselves
as enforcing the regulations,
supposed to be put into
effect in times of scarcity,
which the local magistrates
should have enforced.
And frequently grain riots broke out
where the magistrates had been slow to do
so.
So then writing crowds had an empowering
sense of the rectitude of their
actions,
but of course they weren't simply
disinterested upholders of custom and law.
They will also defending their own
interests and in that endeavor,
riot was a tactic in a kind of
negotiation with local authorities.
Yeah,
very often food riots were preceded
by petitioning petitioning the local
magistrates to act to relieve distress
and to put into operation scarcity
regulations.
It was commonly the case as I've already
observed that such riots came after
weeks of deteriorating
circumstances during which
the local magistrates had been
slow to act.
Hence,
you could see rights
as being in some sense,
a kind of petitioning
in strength and indeed
agrarian riots were
often in a similar way,
a particular stage in a process
of dispute and negotiation
that might include,
for example,
initial appeals to people who had set
in motion and closure schemes to desist
and give them up.
The appeal might come
from the local minister.
It might come from
sympathetic local gentleman.
It might come from the
women of the parish.
It might come from the memorial jury.
If that failed,
then there were a number of informal
sanctions which could be taken to try to
put moral pressure upon those
who were engaged in an enclosure.
So for example,
in 1616 and a village
called over competent,
which is endorse it
down in the south west,
a local and closing landlord who's called
Andrew Abington found a paper stuck on
the church door when he
came to church one Sunday.
The paper read here be Andrew
Abington's commandments and it followed,
thou shall do no right,
thou shalt catch what Thou canst.
Thou shalt pay no man,
thou shall bear false witness
against our neighbors.
Thou shalt denies I known hand that
is deny responsibility and shortly
afterwards and do Abingdon Commandments.
Having embarrassed him at the church
door had been set to music and were being
sung around the local ale houses
as an effort to humiliate him.
Or again,
that could be anonymous stretch.
One landlord in Warrick share in 1,607
received an anonymous letter threatening
that action would be taken if he proceeded
with the enclosure and the letter was
signed,
Thomas on hedge or Thomas unhedged or
another form of action frequently
taken was to initiate lawsuits.
Sometimes tenants would get together and
pool their resources in a common fund
to bring a case at narrow
forest in Somerset,
in the West country.
For example,
tenants anxious to defend the woodlands,
put their purses together as it was put
on the advice of the sympathetic steward
of another local gentleman who gave
them that advice after an open meeting.
And then with that common purpose,
they hired a lawyer to bring a case
to try to prevent the enclosure.
When the riots came,
it was often also a deliberate tactic to
get the case heard in an authoritative
central court,
especially the court of Star
Chamber meeting in Westminster.
The Court of Star Chamber is one of the
highest courts in the land was staffed
with counselors who are often reasonably
sympathetic to the interests of the
local talent tree and who might um,
further their case or forced arbitration
in the interests of preserving public
order.
A riot which could provoke a
landlord to bring a case in.
Star Chamber was an excellent way
of having local grievances heard,
be thought before and authoritative
forum and had the additional advantage of
getting it done at the expense of
the landlord who brought the case.
So there's a tactical element in many
enclosure riots and that's of course an
important reason for
their relative restraint.
They were away of calling the
authorities attention to grievances,
a way of putting pressure on the
authorities to act and to remedy these
discontents.
And surprisingly often it worked.
Magistrates did put emergency
dearth regulations into
operation in the aftermath
of foot rights,
punishments of food riots where usually
relatively few and relatively light or
again,
star chamber or other central courts
quite frequently ordered the settlement of
particular disputes by a
process of arbitration.
And sometimes indeed they even found for
the tenants and for bad the planned in
closure,
but if action on the part of local
people was not restrained in that way,
it could be a very different story.
Uh,
at modern on the coast of
Essex in 1629 for example,
there were two foot rights.
The first of them ended in the
authorities taking action to put scarcity
regulations into effect and punishing
very few people and punishing mode.
I'll need likely when a
second riot took place,
the authorities lost their patients.
A special commission was
sent down from Westminster,
which tried those involved as ringleaders
in the riots and hanged four of them,
including the leader of the
modern riots and Carter,
who was known to her followers,
US Captain Anne or again in Midlands in
1,607 the spread of writing against him,
closure from parish to parish
was eventually deemed by
the authorities to be so
threatening that they defined
it as treasonable rebellion.
Martial law was declared and the rising
was put down with another crop of
executions,
including the execution of the leader.
John Reynolds known to his
followers as Captain Pouch.
He got that name because he had a
leather pouch in which he claimed to have
authority from the king to oppose
and closures when he was taken.
It was founded as pouch
contained his lunch,
some bread and cheese
into,
interestingly in the new Oxford
Dictionary of national biography,
you'll find both and Carter and Captain
Pouch included amongst the dignitaries
of national history,
the our sense of the past is broad
and wide enough to include people who
previously would have had no place.
Well that kind of outcome,
if things were deemed to have gone too
far could very sharply remind the common
people only to graphically of who ruled
in 16th and 17th century England and
that kind of flat repression of
discontent was usually a sign that the
authorities had become nervous.
And it raises a further point,
the usual focus in the literature upon
the relative order and the rationality
and the tactical good sense of popular
protest and on the usual moderation of
response on the part of the authorities.
All of this is true and yet it runs the
risk of making it all seem a little bit
too neat.
A little bit too orderly.
I think we have to remember also that
there was a good deal of danger in all of
this activity.
Sometimes quite serious danger.
Well,
mustn't forget that the participants in
many of these actions were very anxious
and sometimes very angry.
We mustn't forget that sometimes what
began as a specific localized limited
protest could escalate.
The outstanding example is cats rebellion
in 1549 which began as an enclosure
riot and ended of course with open
rebellion and indeed a pitched battle that
was very exceptional.
Nonetheless,
that possibility did exist.
The point is that as a tactic of protest
and as a of negotiation with rulers,
riot could be a rather
dangerous game of brinkmanship.
The authorities for their
part had to try to contain it.
They would expect it to respond.
They had to retain their authority and
their credibility by responding in the
right kind of way.
The crowd for its part
often pushed and menaced,
but it had to avoid going too far.
If it was not to provoke
pretty severe retaliation.
Act of insubordination had to be tricked
out with the appearance of ultimate
deference to authority.
The responses of concession
and conciliation,
which the authorities made had to retain
the appearance of gracious magnanimity
magnanimity on the part of rulers,
concerned rulers.
That was the best way to save their face.
It seems to be the case
that for the most part,
this delicate line was held,
which is in a way a tribute on the
one hand to the skill with which the
leadership of the crowds
conducted their actions.
And on the other hand,
the skill with which many of the
magistrates tried to diffuse what we're,
what we're potentially
very explosive situations.
But of course that doesn't necessarily
mean that the protesters were sincere in
the postures of deference,
which they might adopt in the face of
authority when they negotiated with them.
And it certainly doesn't mean that popular
protest was as some historians have
argued,
essentially unpolitical.
When people describe these
actions as unpolitical,
what they seem to mean is that they
involved no challenge to the authority of
the state
and that they were not indicative of any
revolutionary attempt to overthrow the
established social order.
Well,
of course they didn't.
Even the most determined of protesters
had no alternative model of the social
and political order to appeal to.
There are no conceptions of equal rights.
There are no conceptions of democracy.
They had to work within the structures
of power and authority in a hierarchical
society as they found them.
Their objectives were necessarily limited,
but that doesn't mean that
their objectives are not
political in the sense that
they were attempting to exert some
influence on how power was exercised,
influence on how power was exercised
within their local communities.
These forms of popular protest,
one could say in that sense
where quintessentially political
in the sense that they advanced claims
by local people to be considered,
that they advanced claims
to certain rights to eat,
to enjoy the common
rights,
which they were very aware of even in
a social system that permitted them.
No formal political voice.
They could still have some say in defining
the terms of their subordinate place
in society and they could
achieve limited ends in doing so.
That matters a great deal.
It matters a great deal
because it prevented their
complete alienation from the
existing social order and encouraged
them to seek justice where they felt
aggrieved rather than simply exacting
from time to time a desperate and bloody
revenge and that mattered.
It could matter a great deal in particular
when the country fell into political
crisis in the 1640s
and finally one last point.
The historians who write about popular
protests very often have towards the end
of their studies are
somewhat Lgi Eric Tone.
That's because in the long run,
the defenders of the
customary agrarian order lost.
They lost because the
world that they was trying,
they were trying to defend,
was gradually dissolving all around them.
By the late 17th and early 18th centuries,
the resistance of memorial communities
to agrarian change was very largely over
because such memorial communities
hardly existed anymore.
Communities of tenants with a collective
interest in the customs of the manner
had gradually given
way to a rural society.
Consisting of landlords,
large scale commercial farmers
and landless agricultural
neighbors who possessed
very few rights to defend,
but if that was the case,
the tradition of protest established
in the 16th and 17th centuries did not
entirely die.
Grain rights certainly continued.
They faded out only in the 19th century
when greater agricultural productivity
and modern railway transportation.
Finally,
I endowed and alleviated the inequalities
of supply which had once provoked
those local actions.
That's for the defense of custom.
One could say,
I think that aspect of it were
transferred into another sphere.
Customer might be in
retreat in rural England,
but in the emerging world
of industrial England,
a new world of custom was being born.
It was being born amongst a skilled
journeymen workers of the urban trades
amongst rural weavers,
amongst coal miners and semen
in the growing merchant navy.
In all of these fears,
new customs,
the customs of the trade were being
established and they involved rather like
the older agrarian customs,
certain established
expectations and practices,
expectations regarding fair wages,
decent working conditions,
the proper relationship which should
exist between master and employee.
These people increasingly numerous in
the 17th century were the products of an
emergent capitalist market economy.
They were,
it's children.
They didn't oppose it as such,
but they tried to place their
own limitations on the demands,
which it made upon them
as best they could,
defending their own place
within it structures.
I'm speaking,
of course,
of the earth,
the emergence of the earliest
forms of Labor Organization,
which you find emerging
amongst the journeyman and
manufacturing workers of the
industrial districts from
the late 17th century.
The context had changed,
but the essence of the tradition could
be said to have continued in new ways for
new times.
The age of the manor was ending,
but the age of organized
labor was just beginning.